في ظل اشتداد الحرب والحصار هنا على قطاع
غزه وبالاخص على شمال القطاع تتفاقم
معاناه المواطنين والنازحين هنا في داخل
مراكز الاواء مع تكدس النفايات امام مراكز
الاواء وفي داخل المراكز مما زاد من
ازدياد المرض عند المواطنين وعند الاطفال
ونقل العدوى بين المواطنين في داخل
المدارس على جانب اخر ايضا لا يتوفر اي
امكانيات للبلديات ايه ان يقوموا بنقل هذه
النفايات الى الاماكن المختصه بسبب قصف
الاحتلال
لاليات البلديات
وللجراح في هذه المناطق كما نشاهد هنا
تكدس هذه النفايات بشكل كبير امام مراكز
الايواء مما زاد من نقل العدوى ونقل المرض
بين الاطفال والنساء والمواطنين هنا في
داخل المدارس والامر الان يشتد مع فصل
الشتاء هنا في المراكز طبعا مراكز اللواء
هنا في في مخيم جباليا تضم الاف المواطنين
من جميع مناطق الشمال كما نشاهد هنا لا
يوجد متسع للنفايات لا احد يستطيع نقل
النفايات الى الاماكن المختصه بسبب محاصره
الاحتلال لهذه المناطق هذه معاناه يعانيها
المواطنين في كل يوم وفي كل وقت هنا في
مخيم جباليه ما فيش اي نظافه هنا بتصير
عننا احنا بنظف لحالنا المجاري طافه عننا
هان اولادنا كليتهم امراض واحنا حرام و
حنموت من دون حظ هي اللي بيقولوا عنا تعين
الصحه وتعين غيره لا في نظافه ولا في
جرافات ولا في ميه ولا في اي حاجه الوباء
والجرب والجدري اكل الاولاد اكل واكلنا
احنا الكبار اكلنا اكل فيش علاج فيش اي
وسيله فيشات وسيله حياه بيهتموا في الب
بيهتموا في البقر وفي الغنم اكثر منا احنا
الفلسطينيه نظرا ل الظروف الصحيه الصعبه
التي يعاني منها شمال قطاع غزه في ظل
العدوان الاسرائيل
ونزوح معظم سكان الشمال على الى المدارس
والى اماكن التجمع ه و ومنذ حوالي 83 يوم
84 يوم هذا ادى الى انتشار كثير من
الامراض مثل خاصه النزلات المعويه عند
الاطفال وعند الكبار الصرف الصحي برضه
مدمر مش حد ينظف مش كذا في امراض ووباء
بينتشر بين الناس حاليا خصوصا احنا في وصل
شتاء ا موتش من حرب هيموت من الوباء فتع ك
لوين وصلت الامور فتع كف
بده ناس تشع القمر وتسرع فيه عشان ما تضل
زييك هناك بدات تنتشر لدى الكبار والصغار
التهابات باعلى الجهاز التنفسي والرشوحات
وهي وخاصه ان في كل مدرسه لا يقل عن 3000
الى 4000 نازح وكل فصل مساحته 50 متر مربع
ي يطن فيه او يسكن فيه او ينزح فيه حوالي
70 الى 80 يعني كل شخص اقل من نصف متر الى
60 سم وهذا يؤدي الى سرعه سرعه انتشار
الامراض نحن نقوم في المدارس بانشاء وحده
بسيطه جدا نستقبل بها سواء الاطفال سواء
الكبار نقدم لهم الاسعافات الاوليه
والخدمات البسيطه جدا جدا لا يوجد لدينا
علاج العلاج صفر نحن فقط نسع في المريض
ولا نعالج المريض
وهذه قضيه مهمه لا قدر الله اذا استمر
الوضع بهذا الوضع الانساني السيء سيؤدي
الى كوارث مازالت المعاناه تلاحق
المواطنين هنا في كل مكان كما نشاهد تكدس
النفايات امام مراكز الاواء وفي الشوارع
وفي الطرقات مما زاد من انتشار الوباء بين
المواطنين انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه